apprendre à réparer ces objets plutôt
que de les jeter c'est tout l'objectif
du nouveau rippert café de magny les
hameaux les réparations lieu dans un
local mis à disposition par la mairie
c'était une forte demande des habitants
depuis quelques temps et en fait on a eu
la chance que deux associations et la
même envie au même moment donc vivre à
manille et maniant transition donc voilà
c'est d'éclat nets se sont alignés on en
a profité et ces échanges de savoir
faire sont totalement gratuits via les
et robert café y en a trois il ya
d'abord la lutte contre le gaspillage et
la participation à ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l' indice de réparabilité
donc de conforter cette démarche là un
deuxième est que l'objectif qui est de
transmettre des compétences et les
savoir-faire est elle un troisième qui
est peut-être encore plus important qui
est création le matin le développement
de relations sociales
le concept plaît c'est samedi 29 mai les
bénévoles ont aidé les habitants des
environs à réparer des machines à coudre
des jouets ou encore du matériel
informatique
j'ai apporté mon imprimante parce que
deux fonctionne plus qu'à moitié
à chaque fois que j'ai appris ça sort
des feuilles blanches je laissais
préparée et j'y arrive pas donc je tente
ma chance ici puisque j'aimais bien le
côté de bénévolat ici je trouve ça
génial comme principe que
que des gens nous aident à réparer nos
objets pour éviter que concept ça alors
que ce encore fonctionnel leur hyper
café devrait ouvrir un samedi par mois
les associations cherchent toujours des
outils fonctionnels et des bénévoles